eminem came out of a a city where there
was two white rappers who were
blossoming at the same time which is
crazy
which lets you know there was like a
little underground scene like chris said
on the eight mile or whatever it was a
seven mile wherever
the fifth mile and um and the other
white rapper was her
uh with someone who ended up becoming a
huge trump supporter and country music
singer
um wait my name is
larry the cable guy chad rock larry the
cable guy
who is this kid rock oh kid rock cause
if it's not the 1975 you're not about
about not about it if it's not the pet
shop boys or 1975. i love the 1975's new
song too it's [ __ ]
cute that's gay music it's game music
shirt yep i'm gay
yeah um i like the 1975. i told you why
and here's what's interesting too
you're a straight man with a gay spirit
it's what it is yeah
i've i um i i when i was reading this it
was interesting some people say
some people are old souls you're a gay
son i'm a gay son yeah
i'm yeah i'm a queen yeah um
eminem got in trouble and outraged the
gay and lesbian allegiance against
defamation society they denounced him
they called him a homophobic misogynist
um he had a bad relationship with his
wife um you know used to rap about
killing her but my point is is like do
you think and this is going to be
controversial about to say
but do you think that only happened
because he was white because so many
rappers
talk about they don't like gays and they
talk about objectifying women and people
just don't care
but because he was white these gay and
lesbian
alliance against defamation yes you're
cancelled do you think that
i think with that specific thing yes do
you think then it's
the homophobia part who's woken dope do
you think that this is not like
trying to get you to walk in the lights
just asking no
it's an interesting point that you bring
up i think uh
yeah yeah it's because yes because white
activists
would never attack black would never say
that that's bad that rap album was bad
or maybe they're just not even literally
they would maybe they weren't even
listening until the white guy did it and
that's equally as racist benatia comes
out when she's called she comes out with
a skully hat on her head yeah and then
she comes out with no
shoes or socks but she puts little ear
muffs on her ankles
you know what it actually took you know
what it actually took for a black rapper
to cause a controversy
talk making a song about shooting cops
ice tea
yeah remember that it was like dan
quayle and bush were like all over him
you know that that's interesting freedom
of speech i mean
the ra rappers have kind of been under
fire
like comedians for freedom of speech you
know i guess it's like marilyn manson so
the things that rappers are rappers
saying i mean
the all rapper rap music videos and this
is nothing to do but they were
it's all me too it's all talking about
degrading women but nobody's
it's not nobody cares but in the 90s
they were the republicans
were trying to like create legislation
to like [ __ ]
really well no you can't do that stifle
stifle their uh their music
they need to know they were uh it was
true they were trying real hard a lot of
it was because of the cop killer [ __ ] a
lot of it was like the violence towards
women [ __ ]
um iced tea was very controversial
because of that he had a song called
you know what i say to all that freedom
of speech say and do whatever the hell
you want to do talk about whatever you
want
talk you know whatever you want to say
if you're like too stupid of a human b
if you're that stupid of a human being
you're going to listen to something in a
rap song and then do it because
then get the you're a weak person you're
probably going to do it anyway
yeah i don't know you're not that's not
going to help us get towards the master
race yeah so you know
yeah you need to just i was kid there's
a way where's getting
judged it's just the whole thing yeah
but it is stupid where it's like i've
never heard
a rapper or a musician or a comedian say
something that made me want to go out
and
be violent towards someone or it's all
fear-based [ __ ] it's all like
weak-minded people it's like
majority of people it's like i can hear
a song where eminem is talking about
whatever he's saying defaming gay people
or beating his wife and that doesn't
make me not like gay people it doesn't
make me want to hit my wife
you know so it's like it's i think we're
so scared sometimes
and he's not homophobic and he was never
hitting his wife or he didn't
really want to kill his wife it's called
art it's called uh
lyrics it's called emotional expression
right it's not reality i mean people
can't tell the difference between a
[ __ ] song or a joke
and reality anymore grow the [ __ ] up uh
david
cross had a great bit back in the day
right david cross back in the day is one
of the
best comments yeah and he had uh he was
on i think his like
hbo especially in 99 he said he was
talking about like the people who were
saying um the video games were led to
um you know the columbine shooting and
he goes like oh i'm sorry he goes the
joke was like oh i'm sorry what were the
video games that
adolf hitler was playing yeah
what was the rap songs that he was
listening to right he was you know so
it's like smart yeah it's a good point
guy
yo can you scroll up a little bit mike
you scroll up on the notes
real quick so it was hilarious you just
admitted we're just reading notes off
this down a little bit
wait can you up the cheat sheet a little
bit mikey no up down
no because it was something in 2000 um
go
up yeah well mike uh
marshall marsha mathers he his family
emigrated to detroit
he was born in uh where was he born oh
wait maybe down a little bit he's born
somewhere else
kentucky or some [ __ ] oh yeah [ __ ]
oh yeah
oh yeah no because missouri oh yeah
saint joseph's missouri they call it
listen it's called missouri guy yeah he
did pistol whip his wife though
unfortunately that didn't happen he
pistol-whipped a man he saw kissing his
wife
and he pissed the whipped the man
because he thought he was gay in case
he's just squeaking he's insecure
yeah he's a squeak yeah him and kim have
had a tumultuous relationship yeah it's
more
is uh sounds like you and your baby's
mom i was gonna say this sounds a little
bit
like milo if you got that and then
eminem's mother sued him for defamer in
his song and i might get sued by my
family too
so i got a little bit of an eminem vibe
going yeah well you guys are both very
good at what you do and you just talk
about your personal life a little bit
too much
we really hope you enjoyed that episode
whatever it was about this is just a
stock thing that we're taping on to
every episode
so go make sure you rate review us
subscribe uh turn on your notifications
get jiggy with it
and go to patreon.comridgeboys where
things get really wild